why is the ruble collapsing and what
does it mean basically two explanations
one of them is falling oil prices and
the other is the sanctions about 50
percent of Russia's revenues come from
oil and gas so with the price of a
barrel of oil collapsing from 110
dollars to $60 that's a huge hit to the
country's revenues the second thing is
the sanctions you remember back in
February Russia invaded Crimea the
Russian flag was hoisted above the
Crimean Parliament while President Obama
and other Western leaders responded by
imposing sanctions on the Russian
government and Russian companies we're
making it clear that there are
consequences for their actions
the central bank essentially has two
tools at its disposal one it could dip
into its massive pile of foreign cash
and buy Russian rubles to prompt them up
however they've already done this a few
times and it hasn't worked very well
the second thing Russia can do is
dramatically hike interest rates and
that's exactly what they did early
Tuesday morning the basic idea is if you
increase interest rates you increase the
incentive people have to keep their
money in rubles that works for all of
about 20 minutes after that the Russian
ruble continued its violent downward
spiral losing about 19 percent of its
value in 24 hours essentially fear has
completely taken over the Russian market
as people race for the exits so what's
going to happen the collapsing ruble
will cause inflation to get worse and
the interest rate hikes which they need
to stem the rubles decline will only
deepen the recession
the one way Putin could help himself is
by dialing back the aggression in
Ukraine and hoping the sanctions get
eased but that seems very unlikely the
provocations in Ukraine are the one
thing he's done this year that's been
very popular in Russia it's much easier
for Putin to blame the West for Russia's
problems than to actually do anything
himself